Let me introduce you first.
Okay. Welcome to the DDPS
seminar everyone Before we
introduce our invited speakers,
Speaker invited speaker, let's
go over some rules and
logistics. First of all, please
mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions. If
you have questions you are
welcome to unmute and ask
otherwise, please use chatroom
to post your questions so that
we can address them in q&a
session at the end. Second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences.
Therefore, no classified
discussion is allowed. So please
watch out. Finally, the talk
today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel.
That's about it. Now let me
introduce our speaker today, it
is an honor to host Andrea
Manzoni who is an associate
professor of numerical analysis
at Polytechnique de Milano
Italia since 2020. He received a
master's degree in mathematical
engineering from Politecnico di
Milano in 2008, where he is now
a faculty there, and a PhD in
mathematics from the Ecole
Polytech federal, the EPFL, the
Switzerland in 2012. He is the
author of three books and about
70 papers, he won the numerous
awards including ecommerce and
the Siam ours. His research
interests focus on reduced total
modeling techniques for PDS,
machine learning and deep
learning PD constraint
optimization and uncertainty
quantification, with several
applications including fluid
dynamics, cardiac, cardiac
electrophysiology, computational
mechanics and structural health
monitoring. Today, Andrea will
talk about deep learning for
reduced order modeling, which is
a very interesting topic. Please
enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk. Now without further ado,
let me pass the baton to Andrea
by asking one random person as
usual, today's random question
is,
can you think of the biggest
sacrifice you have made in your
life to be where you are right
now?
I have to say I have to say,
give me maybe half an hour 40
minutes after the talk. Maybe I
will be back to your question.
All right. See ya. So for this
very kind invitation I'm very
happy to be here. I mean, of
course only only only remotely
connected. It's already night
here in almost night evening,
quiet evening in Milan, Italy.
My talk is about deep learning
for how to disorder modeling.
These will be some our our story
of about our research carried
out in the last two years, three
years and a half. And before
starting, of course, I would
like to say acknowledge, I mean,
the people that actually shared
this, this journey about deep
learning in research and
modeling. First of all, Stefania
fresca, postdoc with me here at
Marc's Politecnico di Milano,
Nicola is Franco. He also is a
junior postdoc to the vicar, Chi
Chi now moved to London or to go
but he is a researcher in
another department at the civil
engineering department here in
Milan and Paolo Conte, now
currently PhD student
under my co supervision and the
supervision of another colleague
that is Attila Frangie, food
professor in civil engineering,
department policy, you know,
colleague and dear friend of
mine, also full professor here
of numerical analysis at marks
and then mango Gu, from
University of Twente. He is
assistant professor there and
Jana starvin, is a professor at
EPFL. Lausanne. So, in the three
parts of the talk, so the
contribution I've had the honor
to share with these people will
somehow with some our period,
of course, I don't need I guess
to to convince you that in in
several cases in several
scenario what we need is a good
instance of accurate and
efficient use of the modeling
error. These are the modeling is
key is essential to allow real
time simulation, data
simulation, uncertainty
quantification towards also the
construction of predictive
digital twins. No matter if
you're dealing with say that the
support to clinical decisions or
to structure lead monitoring or
to designing and manufacturing,
sooner or later you need to
carry out say, efficient and
accurate numerical simulation
often are very complex systems.
So the two questions I would
like to address this evening
this morning with you is whether
or not scientific machine
learning can enhance somehow
reduced order modeling somehow.
We just heard that modeling is a
very active research field for
the last I would say at least 20
years but of course new tools
and new algorithms and new ideas
from say scientific machine
learning at large can somehow
finance and I would like to do
Do you at least some cases in
which we are able to enhance the
use of the modeling by using
scientific machine learning of
course, on the other hand, how
do deep learning algorithms
impact on the accuracy and
efficiency of reduced reduced
order models. So, before
starting a sort of global
picture of course, a lot of
approaches have been say
appeared in the last say few
years regarding say both physics
based and data driven methods,
and I've tried to somehow co
locate them on on a line by
looking at the top you have of
course, reduced by these methods
or somehow projection based
techniques to perform a reduced
order modeling I will give you
in a while a very quick
introduction to this.
Of course, in this case, you
still need to solve low
dimensional possibly nonlinear
dynamical systems to get the
solution by going say, down say
you you find non intrusive
reduced basis methods, you
somehow try to still rely on say
maybe subspaces or linear
subspaces, but to carry out the
construction of roms in our in
our less intrusive or possibly
non intrusive, non intrusive
ways and then you also have for
sure physics in for neural
networks in which the
contribution of the say data
driven say way to to build say
of course, ensuring that
fulfilment of physical
constraints, but the use of
neural networks in that case
becomes more more and more
relevant, we are somehow in the
middle
because what I want to do, I
would like to talk a nonlinear
say strategies relying on deep
learning to construct reduced
order models and then the
ingredients I will rely on our
feed forward neural networks out
encoders and somehow I will also
touch a little bit on say, a new
way of dealing with machine
formed neural networks Dheeraj
did these are some of the key
words that I will use say during
during the presentation.
Of course, that the picture is
quite is quite big in my
opinion, we for sure are
interested to develop say that
these are the remodeling relying
on machine learning and deep
learning we could also perform a
sort of algorithmic
argumentation by machine
learning and deep learning
somehow trying to replace those
parts of our use of the model
would that represent a
computational bottlenecks, we
would also be interested in in
performing a sort of Data driven
Learning of physical laws even
if I will not say addressed this
topic.
Today,
we want us to perform a subsidy
quantification once we have
reduced order model and last but
not least, we would also
say rely on approximation theory
to ensure that mathematically
speaking, what we have built is
say accurate in the sense of
some say error estimates and so
on. Of course, at the core at
the middle, we have physical
models in the form of partial
differential equations or say
dynamical systems internal
bodies. And these are some tasks
that we usually face not not
just me, but say quite big
academic research community all
over the world are trying to
somehow face of course, to
perform model discovery or data
simulation regarding say the
learning of physical laws to
approximate the solution to a
given physical problem to say hi
Nance maybe the disorder
modeling construction using
using neural nets are also to
take into account information
and contributions that can come
from different models with
different fidelity. So somehow,
the three keywords that I have
highlighted in blue will be
somehow the the three pillars of
my presentation, I will first
address some possible ideas to
perform the approximation of the
whole solution of the problem.
And then we'll move to say a
possible way to exploit those
ideas also to perform operator
approximation and last but not
least, how to take into account
say, neural networks to perform
also the approximation of some
output quantities of interest in
a multi fidelity framework. So,
these are all say the
connections we have some
applications in mind, I will
show you results regarding these
four classes of problems,
computational mechanics, cardiac
electrophysiology, and then
Frieden omics and also some few
results regarding say micro
electromechanical mechanical
systems. The keywords are
somehow in the middle of these
slides. So I will first address
ideas that are regarding deep
learning based reducer them
models and then I will move to
sort of newer technique, we call
it the pyro MX net how to take
into account a neural network to
perform a better approximation
and last but not least, mostly
fidelity neural network
regression. So, this will be
somehow the outline of of my
talk. So, for the first part, I
will focus on deep learning
based reducer that models before
a couple of words about a
classical way a more classical
way to construct reducer that
models that is projection based
that uses that model. So, I
guess many of you have already
experienced with reduced order
modeling and in particular
disorder modeling of
parameterize systems or
equations that depends on
physical or geometrical
parameters, sooner or later you
need to replace a full order
model with something that is
more more efficient, but still
still accurate of course, full
order models for us are quite a
huge say quite large dimensional
dynamical systems, we want to
approximate the solution in time
for many different parameter
values. And this means that we
have say time derivatives and
then linear and linear
operators. And for for the sake
of simplicity, I will already
rely on a discretized version
think about funny elements or
your best say, your your more
favorite a discretization
technique, we discretize the
space then we ended up with a
quite large scale dynamical
system to solve projection
basically disordered modeling
somehow relies on low
dimensional linear subspaces we
can use for instance proper
orthogonal decomposition and
that is nothing but singular
value decomposition on a given
matrix of snapshots of the of
the form to build say,
a low dimensional hopefully low
dimensional linear subspace in
which we then look for the
solution, we assume in this case
that they say form solution u h
is approximated by a linear
combination of say a few basis
functions or reduced bases,
these are capital N hopefully,
the dimension of these bases is
much smaller than the dimension
n h of the of the initial high
fidelity space and then through
our Galerkin projection or a
more general Petrov Galerkin
projection, we ended up with a
register that model that looks
like the one in the in the green
box. So, now, these shares the
same structure of the of the
Florida model, but now the
dimension and is much smaller
than an age of course, we need
to take care of the assembling
of the efficient assembling of
the operators that appear in
this user the model and this is
the reason why we need to rely
on suitable high production
techniques, this is somehow say
that the global picture
regarding say projection based
disorder models of course, there
are some say
pros and columns in this size in
this context, we we can compute
the the whole fields variable
quickly then we can evaluate any
possible output quantities of
interest that depend on that
solution. Of course, sometime
the assembling of the reduced
order model might become even
more expensive than its solution
and this is of course, a true
computational bottleneck. And
last but not least, even more
crucially, often some problems
are not reducible,
mathematically speaking those
problems that show up as low
decay of the Kolmogorov and with
our say more hardly reducible by
means of these these kinds of of
techniques, this is an example
this is somehow a motivating
example, arising in cardiac
electrophysiology, we have a
nonlinear unsteady reaction
diffusion problem, the variable
that you that that you look on
the on the movie even if they
are a bit lagged unfortunately,
is the electric potential. This
is a very simple test case or
two dimensional say portion of
tissue in which you have three
parameters, the time at which
you deliver say a second
stimulus to the tissue, the
radius of the region, in which
you release the stimulus and
some recovery properties of the
tissue. So,
just three parameters are enough
to make the picture quite
involved, because you may have
very different say, results in
terms of the evolution of the of
the electrical potential here we
have some, say
snapshots in in time and two
different parameter values. On
the left of the slides, you have
the full order model. On the
right you have the reuse of the
model. So everything seems to be
good. But the issue is related
with as low decay of the
singular values related with
both the solutions, snapshots
and the snapshots of the
nonlinear operators that
appealing to the problem. So
even if say the accuracy is is
good, the point is that by
relying goals
on local reduced bases you need
quite large reduced bases and
these of course affect the
efficiency of reuse or the
modeling in this context and
last but not least, even in
presence of local reduced busy
spaces,
pod color caroms might be not
very well suited to problems
that feature coherent structures
that propagate over time. So,
you can also say and up with the
issues related with the
stability in in long time
intervals or on these kind of
methods. So, the reduced
dimension can be potentially not
as small as desired This is
another drawback I bet an action
is costly is an intrusive say
task and these can prevent the
Rams from from being very
efficient. And say even more
importantly around building in
this way must account for all
the variables that are that are
involved in the in the in the
flow of that model. For instance
in this case, the electric
potential is not the only say
variable like for instance in
the Navi stokes equations, you
have velocities and pressures
and if you want to rely on pod
Galerkin ramps you you need to
to approximate both velocity and
pressure.
And these are some of the
drawbacks of these these
techniques. And then we started
to look at this problem for a
problem as slight different
perspective somehow say, noting
that similarity as say Matt,
Matt Matt, many other of course,
authors and groups did somehow
that is a close similarity
between say, proper orthogonal
decomposition that teanaway is
already a task that say allows a
sort of encoding and then a
decoding because, when you have
say that low dimensional
approximation of the solution
use amount decode it to get say,
the high fidelity approximation
of course, this is a linear
operation in the case of pod
this is just a matrix by vector
multiplication and the same two
paths from the high fidelity
space to the low dimensional
space. And somehow encoders can
in a way generalize this kind of
encoding decoding, as soon as
they are say, applied to
snapshots of the floor that
model. So, somehow we start from
data that are generated from the
floater model, these are
snapshots data, and we try to
see if indeed, relying on auto
encoders possibly involving
convolutional layers can say
honeyands This reduction task,
some of the latent
representation that is provided
by an autoencoder awfully is
much lower dimensional than the
one provided my pod of course,
this is obtained through a
nonlinear model that has that
has to be learned. So, this is a
way you say a sort of
parallelism between pod on the
left and then auto encoders on
the right but this is just one
of the two tasks that we have,
because this is just a way to
represent our reduced reduced
order solution at the the other
task is to somehow be able to
replace the generation of of the
reduced order model. And there
is that the first idea we
started from So, deep learning
base that uses the models in a
way carpel two different
architectures that can be
trained both say simultaneously
or say separately. So, a
convolutional auto encoder the
part that you look here in you
have it here in in light blue,
you start from high fidelity
data, and then by using also
some convolutional layers, you
somehow compress the information
that is contained on those data,
as you say, treat images when
you need to compress say,
imaging data say by auto
encoders this is only one part
because the second part is a
deep feed forward neural network
that's from the time and the
parameter vector mu allows us to
generate a low dimensional
representation of the solution.
So, during the training phase,
what we actually do is to train
both networks by taking into
account snapshots of the
problem, say we want to solve
for say times and parameter
values we compute snapshots data
and then we somehow match not
just say the gray parts somehow
the data after the say encoding
and the decoding master look as
close as possible to that the
initial data but also say the
low dimensional representation
is that here is is a given as a
as output from from from the
encoder must match say the
outcome of the defeat photo
neural network because during
the so called Online phase
during the testing stage, what
we want is just to say to rely
on what is here contained in
this read
In a block, and for any new time
and new parameter value, we only
want to evaluate say the
composition of two neural
networks to simply say get these
low dimensional representation
and then decode these to say get
the representation in the in the
high fidelity space. So to be
slightly more technical, we need
to perform two tasks we need to
perform
the learning of the reduced
dynamics and to say learn the
dynamics of the system on this
reduced nonlinear trial
manifold, we use a deep feed
forward neural network offers
these are some options don't
want to say these are the only
options these are some of the
options we found quite quite
quite convenient. And the second
task is the learning of the
nonlinear trial manifold,
because we want to model say,
somehow reducing a unitary
manifold through the decoder
function of a convolutional auto
encoder and the composition. So
you have these decoder and of
the deep feed forward neural
network is what at the end of
the day provides the DL rom
approximation. So, on line at
the very end, we say compute the
deal are approximations by say
evaluating two nets that have
been trained, these are trained
offline. And the training of
these nets requires the solution
of an optimization problem where
say the loss function is made by
those two contributions that
appeared before before in this
slide I sort of say
reconstruction error and sort of
say, close in close match
between say the the low
dimensional representation
provided by the encoder and the
deep feed forward neural
network. All the details, of
course are available in the
papers. And these are collected
at the end of the presentations,
but of course, feel free them to
contact me if you have a further
question and then more detailed,
say questions on any aspects, I
will I will cover now some
results. Regarding on our two
dimensional nonlinear diffusion
reaction problem as the one I
showed you before. Here we have
the full order model. This is
the deal RAM solution with a
latent dimension equal to three,
here we have two parameters that
are the coordinates of the
stimulus that is released to say
in this small portion of tissue
plus time. And this is not my
chance that we have decided to
fix two, three, the reduced
dimension, the comparison is
clearly in favor of this deep
learning based use of the
models, this only takes a less
than two seconds on a CPU and
less than half a second or GPU
to get the new solution for the
new say, choice of the parameter
values against say that the 14
seconds political or Koran, or
eight seconds or a political ad
can run relying on on local
reduced basis function. This is
of course, an initial site test
case area via slightly more
challenging example where you
spend hours in this case
changing say the location of the
position where you release
these, the second stimulus in
this once again, nonlinear
reaction diffusion problem. And
those in this case, the
comparison is between the 15
seconds. DRAM takes online to
run and to perform CD
approximation on CPU less than a
couple of seconds on a GPU
against more than, say, six
minutes for the form and say,
one minute and a half or half a
minute for, say our Aguilar
camera. And do you have also the
behavior of the error on the
test scheme on the testing sets
a in time and the error states
of course under the desired
trash.
So, that's that a couple of
slides now for commenting maybe
a bit more these aspects related
on the choice of these reduced
or latent dimension. And of
course, in the case of pod, we
clearly have some indication
from the decay of the singular
values where to say truncate
where to chop the pod expansion,
but how to perform these in the
case of deep learning based on
the models what we took
inspiration from some works by
the VOR and co authors of some
some years ago, somehow
introducing and then taking
advantage of sort of nonlinear
extension of the Kolmogorov and
with the usual say, mathematical
concept that is say used to
evaluate the reducibility when
you rely on linear subspaces
we somehow have that in the case
of say architecture like the one
I showed you before. Here
notation is slightly different
because you have say, an encoder
side prime sorry a decoder side
and then these feed forward
neural network fight. While it
is possible, at least for say
linear
elliptic PDE is we started from
saying analytic PDS, it is
possible to show that say
depending on the number p of the
parameters that are involved in
the problem, we can somehow
bound or also somehow try to
compare how these say Layton
dimension must behave and for
instance, if the parameter to
solution mapping is say
fulfilling some regularity
assumptions, you can also show
that say these latent dimension
can be chosen as being equal to
the number of the of the
parameters and the details of
those results are reported in
these say recently accepted on
mathematics of computation paper
that is that is say highlighted
highlighted here.
This is a one part say of the
results contained in that paper
that the second part is also
related with a sort of say,
guidelines to construct those
architectures. So, assuming that
once again some regularity
assumptions are are fulfilled
regarding the parameter solution
map, we can say link say the the
accuracy in terms of a tolerance
upside and we have say on the
two error contributions, we have
to bound the sort of
reconstruction error and the
sort of parametric error, we can
somehow ensure that the error is
below under a given threshold
and as a function of this
threshold we can also say assess
how many for instance active
weights and layers must be
considered in both say that the
outer encoder and the feed
forward neural network so, that
is of course, a ongoing activity
on that generalization of this
kind of say results also to
other kinds of architectures.
But, we started some hours to to
to, to provide a sort of say
mathematical say
theoretical ground on on this.
Of course, this is not the
entire story, because, if it is
true that the dimension of the
deep learning reduced order
models can be kept very small,
hopefully say is equal to the
number of parameters that are
involved. It is also true that
the DL rom can be queried at any
desired time, I don't need to
solve any dynamical system to
compute a solution until a given
say time capital T, I can query
the DL rom online for any time
in the SE training range, I
would say
we avoid expensive production
techniques, this is another say
good achievement. But on the
other hand, in this setting the
DL roms still require quite
expensive training stage if the
size of the Florida model NH is
is very large, this is because
we need to reduce the amount of
data from a dimension and age to
a very small dimension, but the
problem the bottleneck is is NH
and then we move to a say a sort
of
summer we decided to take the
best features of DL ROMs and pod
to some old couple them to say
design these new pod DL rom
architecture This means that the
first layer somehow that the
first dimensionality reduction
is somehow performed through pod
no matter if that dimension of
the pod space here is quite
large or even larger than say
what expected is only relying on
pod because then once we say
performer first reduction saved
from 1 million of degrees of
freedom to 10 1000s then we can
apply to that pod projection of
the snapshots data that the raw
machinery we have just
introduced. So somehow we
leverage on say, both good
features that the RAM has to say
perform an incredible
dimensionality reduction say
until the parameter dimension
say and what pod is able to do
in order to say perform linear
dimensionality reduction that in
this case is only say that the
first say reduction layers now.
So notation is slightly
different than the D ID at the
end is say the same as before we
want to match somehow the two
didn't the data that we're
having gray here. So the
projection in the pod space and
the reconstruction of them and
then the to say low dimensional
representations that say at
Come out of the encoder and have
this deep feed forward neural
network. So
I have a question. So if you
probably want the pod basis size
to be pretty big, because the
overall accuracy will be bounded
by the pod. Absolutely. Yeah.
Yeah, you're totally right.
In the cases, I mean, I'm going
to show indeed, of course, that
the dimension of the pod can be
quite large, but somehow this is
already say a sort of reduction
compared to the initial size say
NH of the of the fluid model. So
no matter if say, The Beauty
dimension is 1000s or 10 1000s.
Well, if you start from data
that leaving 1 million
dimensions because of these very
fine discretization this is
already say a good achievement.
But of course, yes, you're 30
right into the pod dimension
somehow
bounds bounce some out the final
accuracy of this, I don't want
to say that this is the only say
way to go, but at least this
will say one of the most
straightforward options, we we
will try to this is not the only
ingredient. We also relied on
randomized SVD too far further
reduce competition all times and
also on a sort of say pre
training strategy, in which we
decided first to train a model
for our simple task and then
using that train model to to
initialize the second training
on the more complex tasks that
we need to face for instance, we
try to change the constitutive
law and then to start to say
training a network by relying on
a simpler constitutive law
regarding for instance, examples
in competition mechanics and
then say passing to them say
conservative law we wanted or we
also tried to learn say the nets
on a smaller ranging time and
then say, perform a second
training for the final time
range, we we want it these are
some results, in which indeed
also these sorts of pre training
shows that the total time
regarding training can be
further reduced from one hour to
say 15 minutes, this is quite a
simple example of say,
computational mechanics, we have
a list of the nomics of these a
simple beam structure at the
very end, the testing can be can
be performed in a very, very
fast time.
Similar results in collaboration
with say a project regarding say
the modeling of say of the
cardiac activity here we have
cardiac electrophysiology on
ventricle on top on an atrium
and here at the bottom, and here
you have parameters that are
related once again with a
position of stimuli, these are
simulations that takes more than
three hours for say our final
element follow the model of
course, we need to pay more than
say one day regarding say the
construction of snapshots and
then say a first reduction one
hour of training of this
periodical ROM, but all this
allows us to perform online
evaluation for new say locations
regarding say that there is of
the stimulus in say in a skillet
is in the real time because this
is more or less the scale
regarding time that this
phenomenon say actually takes
takes place and the same safe
for for for for an atrium in
which they simulation time
online is less than 0.2 seconds.
These are some LPDDR roms allows
us to get say even faster or say
as fast as real time solutions.
These are results regarding
fruit and AmEx that the
techniques is extremely general
because it only relies solely on
on data extracted from from
simulations. And then we also
enjoyed say, the use of this
technique on different physical
say problems here you have the
the usual benchmark for foreign
stocks flowing out in a pipe the
flow pastor cylinder, where it's
a new new solution for new
parameter values can be very
quickly computed
this is say the flow. So, this
is still the the flow pastor
cylinder in which we also have
the approximation not only of
the velocity, but also the
pressure provided of course
pressure data are available and
given to the to the network. So
everything can be easily
generalized also to the case in
which we have more than a single
variable to approximate
and also the evaluation of
outputs is indeed is indeed very
accurate. This is what happens
in the case of more involved
fluid flow. This is our blood
flow in a cerebral aneurysm
geometry, where the parameters
are related with the inflow in
time. So here we have the
comparison of the float that
model of an element the pod
around here, the main
Oh and the error that is order
of 10 to the minus five taking
of course the comparison between
the two and if you look at that,
say that they are the flow
pattern into into the aneurysm
indeed you cannot say find So,
big differences, you have these
reported at the bottom and then
it could continue with this an
example with fluid structure
interaction where we have the
usual say
solid the formation of this
elastic beam attached to a fixed
rigid square block and this is
the velocity say pattern
regarding say the flutter model
on the left and two different
say cases and then the
corresponding pod DL rom
approximation. So, no matter if
say also the complexity of the
problem maybe say increases a
little bit there are no big
substantial changes in the
architecture of the pod and ROM
and also in the case of vector
field variables essentially the
different valuable components
can be can be grouped together
and then treat it say and by
BioPure detail from last but not
least, we also apply this to the
to the analysis in the
simulation on the mechanical
behavior of these micro
electromechanical systems.
These are say tiny components
that you that you can find for
instance in any smartphone we we
have in our in our pocket some
micro mirrors or things like
that, where you the the interest
is to characterize the So,
called frequency response
function because you have say
loading on these structures
describing terms for instance of
amplitude and frequency
parameters and then you want to
assess for instance the maximum
say deflection of these
components that features some
internal geometric
nonlinearities in the in the way
the these deforms, and at the
end, you can for instance
evaluate say a lot of
combinations regarding different
say frequencies and and and
apply it to the off the load
somehow in a in a couple of
minutes. And what that say, I
followed that model would I have
required more bones than that
then I hear because of the need
to say to to perform very long
long time sake simulation in
this context.
So, this was say everything that
I gotta think to the first part
of course, there are also some
say
extensions, further extensions,
more aspects regarding both time
extrapolation, if you want to go
beyond say that the time window
in which you have observed data,
we somehow try to rely on long
short term memory networks to
perform say time extrapolation
and we also introduced a sort of
meshing formed layers to take
into account the fact that
indeed the data we are dealing
with say
are related to our competition
Nash where we perform say the
computations to get those
snapshots and somehow we decided
to say specify the structure of
a network by taking into account
say the connected matrices the
relationships essentially
between among the vertices of
the mesh, so, somehow we will
also be able to to make the
neural network structure
geometry aware, and this can be
somehow an alternative say, way
to perform, say a further
reduction in the training to the
pod we introduced before somehow
here we decide to set to zero a
lot of weights and biases in our
network somehow those that are
related with interactions among
say, points that in the mesh are
very far from each other. And
these of course, have a strong
impacts they also on the, on the
training, say performances of
that kind of, say architecture.
So, the details are on those
two, archive preprints if you're
interested in you can have a
look. So, this is the end of
the, say, first part, the second
and the third part, of course,
will be say shorter than the
first one, so don't worry about
that. In the second part, if you
don't have say, questions
regarding the this was part of
that was it can take here a
short short break and then it
can answer to your question if
you have.
So, there are questions from
from chat room, but there are
many Okay, there maybe we wait
until the end of the okay okay.
Okay. So, in the second part,
somehow we try to take advantage
of this framework to perform
say, operator approximation. So
now we we know that soon as we
perform the construction of
projection base that you started
the models sooner or later you
need to take into account tax
reduction to be able to
To assemble nonlinear terms for
instance in an efficient way,
so, but very often and this is a
case that we found for instance
in computational mechanics,
where we have say quite involved
in a linear constitutive laws
for for the material, it might
be the case that the pod
dimension is quite small,
because say the parameter to
solution mapper is quite a is
good regarding the reusability
through a linear subspace but,
what is a often annoying is the
fact that those say operators at
the reduced level require say a
lot of say basis functions to be
to be approximated in the case
you rely for instance on the
discrete empirical
interpolation, okay. So, in an
earlier case in which you need
to rely on say, reduce Newton
problem, for instance, Newton
iteration teach timestamp if you
do everything fully implicit,
well, you end up with say, an
iPad rom where, say your
Jacobean matrix Jn and your user
syllable en se must be
approximated on a given basis.
And the basis must be computed
through snapshots starting from
snapshots of their nonlinear
terms of the residuals and then
of the needle Jacoby's. This
means that if you don't have a
sufficiently reach approximation
in terms of operator
approximations, also say that
the overall Newton iterations
can be for instance not
converging or you might generate
Of course, large large errors
that then accumulate in time.
So, in these slides, I just
recalled for those of you who
are less acquainted say with for
instance, this could implicate
interpolation, how this somehow
looks like you want to perform a
linear approximation of the
residual and then you take
derivatives to have the Jacobian
approximation. And then at a
selected set of points is called
magic points in the initial
paper by mme quarters, you have
to set a certain number of
interpolation constraints to
match say that reduce the
presentation with the ones that
you would obtain by only looping
on those elements on the on the
initial match, this is of
course, extremely intrusive
procedure.
So, we decided to, to see if say
diviner networks could also be
used to perform operator
approximation. So, somehow the
pyro net the technique we ended
up with is a projection based
technique in which say, the
operators at the reduced level
meaning the residual and the
Jacobian in the ROM are
approximated through the DL rom
approach we introduced before.
So somehow, rather than using
snapshots of the solution, I say
use snapshots of residual
vectors and Jacobian matrices
already at the reduced level.
So, this means that these are
quite small dimensional data,
because in those cases, the PD
dimension is quite small
regarding the solution
approximation. And then I
perform the training of the same
network we saw before to be able
online to compute reduced reduce
factors regarding the residual
and reduced matrices regarding
the Cobian by simply evaluating
online testing stage or neural
net.
I skipped those details, because
it's becoming say quite late,
you can find them on the paper,
but the message is the same kind
of architecture. So, an
autoencoder plus a feed forward
neural network is what indeed
can be used also to perform
operator approximation here
there are some results in which
indeed the speed up is
remarkable if if operators are
approximated through through
neural networks,
what is what is good in this
case is that errors in time of
course, do not grow more than
say what the global errors
regarding both production and
high production DT Do you have
some some example for instance
regarding say, a beam case in
which you have say a parameter
dependence by the model of the
structure for instance, and then
we also perform some analysis
regarding both the impact of the
training sample size of course,
you need say sufficiently large
samples to train the network's
and also which is the impact on
the pod dimension for the
solution approximation. And
similar results were obtained on
us slightly more say involved
case in which you have the
contraction of an extremely
idealized say, vertical this is
actually half an ellipsoid up
really geometry also in this
case, the errors are regarding
say both pod projection for the
solution and then these operator
approximation do not say grow in
time with say remarkable
speedups compared to our to our
floor, their model and to our
pod Galerkin dime, ready sorter
model. So now in this case, what
was really limiting say the
efficiency of the ram was the
high production stage because
the peel
V reduction is already quite
good in order to say,
drastically reduce the dimension
of the of the solution space.
And this was the reason why we
actually took advantage of, say,
DL roms to perform, say,
operator approximation. Third.
And last part. Remember, we
started from the need of
approximating the solution, then
we move to the operator
approximation. And last but not
least the how to take into
account neural nets to perform
output approximation in our sort
of multi fidelity framework.
So, the goal is to approximate
in this case, a high fidelity
model, and FhF, leveraging few
data, possibly few data from the
high fidelity model and several
data from the low fidelity
model. So, for the time being,
we only have two Fidelity's. And
we explored essentially three
options a sort of intermediate
option where we directly model
the high fidelity function
training as sort of only one
network that takes both low
fidelity 9080 data and
considering the low fidelity
output as a sort of intermediate
level in this sort of two step
approach in which we first
learn, say the relationship
between say, the low fidelity
and the high fidelity data. In
case of course, we have both on
a limited set amount of samples.
And then we say somehow try to
learn the
set say we start solid first to
learn that low fidelity model
from the input of the low
fidelity model to the output the
output and then we take
advantage of this approximation.
And then we give to our second
network that somehow puts
together the available I
fidelity data and that say,
artificially generated high
fidelity data from this first
network, this was the second
option, a third option. So now
added a third network in between
to model somehow the linear
correlation between the high
fidelity and they're affiliated
data in a sort of say,
incremental approach in which we
You start by learning say the
linear correlation among them
and then you focus a more on the
output correction that you that
you need, we took advantage of
those say, architectures to
police us rely on poor or
reduced off their model
approximation, suppose that you
have say a pod Galerkin
Richard the model this is our
CDL miles case,
depending on some parameters,
say the wave number, the angular
frequency, and some geometrical
parameters regarding say, the
shape of these acoustic horn we
want to in this case, evaluate
an output quantity of interest.
So we are not interested to the
whole say, solution field, but
only to our work to an output of
interest. And then we have a low
fidelity model that is given by
a pod Galerkin dime. But for
instance, you you may rely on
our poor dime approximation if
you don't want to say rely on
very rich operator approximation
or on a poor pod basis. For
whatever reason, the high
fidelity data are the ones that
comes from that identity
simulation, find it elements say
these are results regarding for
instance, what happens in the
case a different sizes in terms
of basis function, so the
different Fidelity's of the low
fidelity model somehow and
different amount of high
fidelity data somehow combine to
give you at the end of the day,
say the approximation of the of
the output then the our findings
were that say these sort of two
steps or three steps way to
combine data, were say much more
accurate than say that
intermediate structure where all
the data were seen by the
network in in in a single shot,
I would say the size of the use
bases clearly impact on the
accuracy of the low fidelity
output, the high fidelity output
is in black. It's clear that if
the US bases all lead contains
very very few bases, the output
is a totally different story.
This is extremely inaccurate.
Nevertheless, the message is at
the end, no matter if the low
fidelity output is not as
accurate as the OSI or the multi
fidelity framework can somehow
combined together a lot of low
fidelity output and few very
accurate high fidelity output.
So only a few of us basis
functions are considered to deal
with a potentially inaccurate or
very inaccurate low fidelity
model. Clearly, as soon as the
ICA data, say increase or
business functions increase
predictions are better.
The intermediate model has as
poor predictive accuracy
See without a sufficiently
accurate low fidelity model, but
this was not the case of our two
step or three step models. So,
you can be a bit safer regarding
say the, the poor fidelity of
the low fidelity model, if you
say combine those two steps or
three steps, and then we decided
to extend these are more recent
results to extend these two time
dependent outputs somehow
injecting here LSDM cells. So,
once again suitable neural
networks that take into account
also that the time dependent
behavior, because what we
realized is that say by simply
considering those architectures
with time dependent data was not
enough to get very accurate
prediction of time dependent
output. So, at the end of the
day, the architecture
reconsidered as the same, but
now feature also layer here that
take into account LSDM networks.
And they skip these results for
instance, what
I only say briefly, here you
have a problem where you have a
low dimensional dynamical
system, a lot couples data, one
with three species or three
dimensional dynamical system,
where somehow we have low
fidelity data on a quite long
range, high fidelity data on a
say on a short range. And here
you have the comparison between
a single fidelity say LSDM model
but only related on low fidelity
data, while the the shift
somehow in say the frequency
also say, is observed.
If you rely on isolated data,
well, the accuracy is good as
soon as you have the data but in
in the time range. And we were
we only ever looked at data
while the prediction gets worse
and worse, while our y's say
combination of say low fidelity
data, potentially inaccurate,
but available, and few ICT data
allows on for instance, two step
architecture featuring LSDM
layers to get a accurate
prediction of the output also
say in the time range in which
data are not available. And
these are somehow quite similar
results. Regarding for instance,
our problem where we add say a
one dimensional model domain
equation, this is say the value
of u of the solution. So, the V
here the electric potential at
that point for varying
parameters and running time. So,
you have say, a behavior or a
given behavior of the solution
that somehow is quite quite
different if, say low fidelity,
high fidelity
data are are used. Now, we
combined together low fidelity
and high fidelity data. So here
you have the error between say
the true what we want to
approximate and what we obtain.
On the first row we only have
single fidelity, say
architecture. So this means that
as soon as you use LSTM our
situation improves, but if we
only rely solely on low fidelity
data, well, clearly situation is
quite is quite bad. Using LSTMs
on high fidelity data is good,
but the point is that isolated
data can be can be very few. So
what happens in in a multi
fidelity case? Well, in a multi
fidelity case without LSTMs.
Well the situation is not good
as desired, because you have say
quite large errors. And in the
second row say second, third and
fourth picture, you have the say
the good errors that are
obtained, for instance by
relying on a two step or even
better a three step say
architecture featuring than LSTM
layers. So LSDM Layers allow us
to
take advantage of this multi
fidelity framework to perform
also evaluation of time
dependent outputs, leveraging
say on few isolated data and say
possibly many more low fidelity
ones.
So to conclude, I hope to say to
you I've been able to show that
say deep learning enhanced the
use of their models, say can can
can be of help
provided I satisfied his
accuracy, provided we are able
to control the computational
effort to say tackle some of the
problems that are listed in
those bubbles. So different
physical, different physics
based models.
Potentially Amanda we could use
these disorder models to face
several many quality scenarios
so that the keywords is a
disorder modeling UCLA
origin all those cases
of course, you may ask what
happens regarding the need of
ensuring physical constraints
all what I've shown before this
movie here at the bottom. So,
now was taking into account
physics only through the
snapshots data, but we are
currently working and maybe say
now, next time we are in say,
few months. In the future, I
will be also able to show us in
a more structured way some
results for which we already
have initial results. Here we
have say that the forecast for
instance, in time after say, the
time range in which we observed
the data
without a physics based terms,
and we have found a good way,
details are still a bit under
investigation regarding say the
possibility to inject also
physics in this kind of
architecture. And you usually
see that situation regarding
time forecasts, say out of the
say, training window is is much
better. So more results we hope
will follow soon. I stopped
here, I listed in the slide some
some references. If you are
interested in of course, please
have a look or an email, if you
want to have a more detail.
And they leave you with some of
the picture you could take from
exactly this window here.
My back say a couple of hours
ago. This is our campus and
Milano the city center is is on
the back. So thank you very much
for your kind invitation and
your attention. Thank you. Thank
you so much for the wonderful
talk. Well, it is a real picture
you just taken on on our right.
Yeah, did this was here. This is
what actually I can can look
from, say my window of my office
that is our campus. All right.
Sounds good. Okay, so we have a
many questions to cover. There
are many questions in me,
actually tried to find various.
Alright, so the first question
is from John,
on Texas a&m. And he asked, in
the very, very beginning, you
have a slide about, you know,
the physics based and even
slides show that I'll be methods
to be high on the physics axis,
but low on the data driven axis.
But I'll be methods collecting
snapshots and discover the RV
spaces. So they will be data
driven techniques as well. Can
you clarify, I agree, I agree
with with John. Actually, of
course, this was a possible way
to convey in a single slides, of
course, the plurality of
different techniques and how my
focus was maybe more on the way
the use or the model and then a
result that approximation is
generated.
I totally agree with you about
the fact that of course, these
are say also data driven
techniques in the sense that of
course, we need to take
advantage of snapshots of our
Florida model to generate their
use or their approximations, but
somehow, the way in which the
reducer the model is built a
steel takes into account a
physical problem we started
from. So in this sense, somehow
I put say,
at the very say, top of this
slide, say reduced business
methods, also, because these are
the kinds of techniques I
started from, say some some
years ago, I totally agree with
them, I guess it was a relative
measure. Alright, another
question from John. Isn't there
also a parameter dependent
latent representation that one
needs to learn between the pod
and the DL stages?
Let's say
so far, we've dealt with say
say a quite limited number of
parameters if this is the
question by hand. So, we already
have say physical parameters
that affect say the problem that
could also potentially be
related with geometrical save
variations, but somehow these
are our input parameters. So if
the question is related with the
need of learning also sort of
parametric description of the
inputs, this would be say
another maybe layer two to be
added.
There the representation that on
the other end is learned for
instance, by the feed forward
neural network is intrinsically
parameter dependent, because
there's actually say, a way to
map say parameters and time if
you have time to these low
dimensional, say it's base of
the of the latent variables.
So I look to to, to to to answer
to John question. All right.
Sounds good.
Okay,
percent about the
customer from the rap. What
about a chaotic system? How well
does this approach deal with the
chaotic systems like? Well, we
would like to know
on how it of course performs say
on more and more involved cases.
I've got this is your to
challenge and this is still an
open challenge to me say
predicting forward in time say
regarding the the range in which
you collected snapshots data is
already sacred challenging for
non chaotic say dynamical
systems and then it can imagine
the kind of difficulty you may
find in the case of say
extrapolating forward in time.
So, forecasting essentially the
solution of the problem out of
the, say, training range just
for a small time forecast.
Another maybe a key task that is
related to this is the fact that
we could also be interested
potentially in extrapolating the
behavior of the solution out of
the parameter range in which we
collected the data. So, somehow
the network learns, say, what
the data
bringing as, as information, of
course, we cannot say, imagine
to be able to approximate unless
we provide new physics inspired
or physics informed or driven
terms into this, this procedure,
maybe that can say, play an
essential role in order to shed
some light on possible say, I
don't want to say chaotic
system, but say, less is more or
less regular dynamics already,
for instance, are periodic, say,
systems already, say poses some
small challenges and maybe some
challenges? Well, I just wanted
to say like, the cardiac stuff,
since you already have cardiac
simulations. Yeah, it's pretty
easy to drive the cardiac stuff
into a chaotic space. So
as soon as say you have say,
spiral waves that a somehow
break down, essentially, we we
add the results I didn't put,
yes, your your comment. Thanks.
Thanks, Rob, about this after
your comment allows me to say
something more, we essentially
dealt with a case where we had
say that the backup of those say
spiral ways France. In that
case, indeed, we were able to
approximate the solution, at
least in the time range in which
we collected the data. So
supposing that the data were
already reflecting that kind of
behavior. So backup, say of
those, say France, we were able
to reproduce them for new
parameter values. But in that
same time window, this is this
is for sure. True. So at least
say, in this case, there is
there is much hope. Thanks for
marking this. All right. Sounds
good. Can we go back to John's
question, like his second
question about parameter
dependent representation? So
unfortunately, he he does not
have a microphone available. So
he's relying on the chat.
I wish he if he can just
intervene and ask that but he
just gave me the clarification.
The question is more about the
latent code that live in between
pod and and deep learning
stages. Okay. Yeah, these indeed
also somehow reflect say, the
parameter dependence, somehow,
the network is trained by taking
into account data that have been
computed for different parameter
values. So somehow, in that
case, you are representing you
are attempting to represent the
structure of the social
manifold, essentially, as pod
does. When pod is applied to to
a bunch of SNAP, let's say
computers for different
parameter values. So in that
case, you are somehow coding
with that, say Latin
representation. Say that they're
all solution manifold that is
intrinsically parameter
dependent, right. And then of
course, for any new parameter
value, I need to find and this
is the second part of the DRAM
architecture need to find a way
to connect a time and parameters
to the low dimensional code.
So I have to have a better
clarified maybe this aspect to
John, but if this is not the
case, of course, we can keep on
discussing. I guess you guys can
exchange email and then yeah,
sure.
Yeah, sounds good. Okay. Next
question is by Jessie from
Stanford. She's asking since
this approach, you know, she's
talking over the pod.
Since this approach still uses
pod data, how does this approach
better approximate problems with
large Kolmogorov and with good
Pinteresting
And somehow we took advantage of
pod as already Yong Soo was
mentioning before with this
question
of course to enhance even more
say the reduction that is
carried out through a linear
technique like pod indeed for
instance So, already say cardiac
electrophysiology for instance
is already a problem where the
Kolmogorov and weight decay is
pretty bad is very slow because
of that say quite complicated
parameter to solution dependence
right. So, the partial say
conclusion we have reached So,
far is that we can afford for
dealing with say quite large pod
spaces
and you may think to take into
accounts a sufficiently large
pod spaces
a pod dimension that would be
totally
ineffective if that was the only
reduction stage like in our pod
Galerkin way,
no matter if that pod space is
quite large dimensional while
the DL rom machinery somehow
then farther reduces
dimensionality So, for the time
being the only say partial
answer, I totally agree with you
this is not a complete answer
is to try somehow to rely on
sufficiently large dimensional
3d space or we haven't tried yet
to rely on maybe local pod
spaces that was already a way to
say tackle the problem of the of
this logic of the Kolmogorov
went with but I totally agree
with you that this is a say
quite open issue yet right.
Great. Next question is by
evening. He asked for the second
option of MF nn are the
structures of the second neural
network neural network for LS
and neural network for HF the
same if not router HF neural
network more complicated than we
say these are densenet In both
cases, then all the details
regarding for instance, that the
construction in terms of
complexity of the of the
architectures are reporting the
papers. So please have a look on
that.
I would say the
goal of the tonight's is
slightly different, because the
first net needs to learn the
relationship between the input
and the low fidelity output. The
second net are more like a
correction by say bringing love
data outputs to high fidelity
output. So, the first nets So,
the tasks that the two nets must
perform are intrinsically
different. The one is more of an
input output say learning task.
The second is more say a sort of
conversion between low fidelity
outputs to hijack outputs. So
the structure is lots of
different we then say perform a
certain kind of training in the
in the paper. So also the
details regarding the procedure
we followed up for the training
are reported there. Diff Of
course, you still have say, more
detailed and quick questions
related to this. Of course, feel
free to write me and then we can
can exchange ideas on this as
well. Awesome. Sounds good.
Okay, great. We don't have any
other question in chat room.
It's a minutes past 11 Already
either it is the ATM over there.
Right? Is 28 is eight is 8pm.
Yeah, well, thank you for
staying late with us. very
gracious from your side. Thank
you. Well,
let's wrap up. So let's thank
our speaker today for the
wonderful talk. And if you have
more questions please feel free
to email him email and Andrea
directly I'm sure he's going to
be happy to answer any
questions. That is my email
address indeed pay attention to
this one that follows my name
unfortunately under
one.manzoni.palmi.at polimer
dot.it Thanks to you and Jung
Soo once again for for this very
kind and invitation I liked a
lot and enjoyed about to to to
give this presentation hopefully
say we will be in touch and feel
free of course to write me a
comment to all the people
attended for any kind of say,
question. Sounds good. Thank you
so much. Okay. All right. Bye
bye.